there are certain things that men do the
woman just hate and that's what we're
talking about in this video I'm Daniel
and you're watching DLM model lifestyle
Now we made a list of 10 things that
men do that women hate. So let's start
with number 1. Number 1: Woman hate
it if guys talk too much about themselves
you've met those guys they just go on
and on and on about themselves.  It just
basically tells a woman that he is
selfish self-absorbed and he's got an
ego that nobody likes. Number 2 is when
a guy smells bad. I mean I get it we all
have different smells right but if a guy
cannot take 10 minutes just to take a
shower and put some deodorant on... no just
no... and if you're one of those guys that
say I'm too lazy to shower just stop and
think about what you're saying.
Number 3 is catcalling. Woman hate it
when a man drives past a woman
and he yells or he whistles.  You know it
just it makes them feel  disrespected
number one and number two it makes them
feel cheap
Number 4 when a man acts differently
in front of his friends. If a man act
weird or different in front of his
friends it immediately tells a woman two
things: He cares more about his friends
than her and number two he cannot be
trusted. Number 5
woman hates it when a man does not all
listen to her.
Especially when a guy looks on his phone
or the other direction when she's busy
talking. If she's talking look her in the
eyes and show her that you really care
about what she thinks and feels.
Number 6 is when men have long dirty nails.
Eeeuw, disgusting... and then those men are
shocked when a woman don't want them to
come near them.
7 is lying men
Women hates a guy that lies. No relationship
can be built upon lies and it just takes
one lie to destroy a person's integrity.
Number 8 is guys who never laugh
I know there's different personalities
out there and some people are more
serious right so it's okay to be a
serious guy but if you never ever laugh
with a woman she will think you hate life
or worse you hate her.
Number 9 is not asking her questions
about her life now I don't mean to throw
a lot of questions at a woman and like
she feels interrogated no, hahaha. But a woman
will feel like you don't really care if
you don't ask her about her life
Number 10 is when men don't care about the way
they look. It's okay if men are not
really interested in fashion and just
want to be the way that they are but if
men have an attitude of I couldn't care
less about being presentable especially
with women... it's not a good idea. All
right if you liked the video give me a
thumbs up subscribe and then that's it
cheers guys